guess who's going back to the motherland
it's a big deal going to your birth
country I used to talk about it all the
time when we're little remember Grand
Adventure to find your birth mother so
proud of you
hi everyone and welcome to the big
ticket interview for Joyride
what are your biggest road trips do's
and don'ts good music dudes do bring
snacks yeah do eat potato chips a huge
fan of gas station beef jerky uh
my gas station uh top two picks
Flamin Hot Funyuns and pound cake you
are a pound cake
the flaming hot pound cake that was
amazing she lost a pound yeah she loves
I also love peeing outside so windows
down I will I don't don't worry
um and I mean that's so metaphorically
emotionally I will strangle you if you
try to play I Spy I think that's the
worst game I've ever heard of oh
especially on a road trip you're like I
spy with my little eye I like it has
like my little eyes
all right yeah
yeah in your own life what was your
biggest travel nightmare every travel
experience every time filming for this
movie
every time her luggage has been lost
every time yeah every time we've gone to
like a press event for this or like when
we were filming in Vancouver my suitcase
gets stuck in customs or in Idaho or
something like it just is gone also in
South by Southwest half of our teams
didn't make it because there's
thunderstorms yeah we adapt we adapt and
we adjust and we're quick on the Fly I
thought it was cute you you met you lost
your suitcase and then I got to give you
my t-shirt and that was our very first
like hi stuff wait and then which
pajamas in Austin yeah yeah and so one
more time and then you're gonna have to
give me your Mumu
change panties right now on camera it's
too much you know what no spoilers I
forgot on my way she's all talk by the
way
for the reshoots I forgot my passport at
the airport yeah yeah
[Music]
amumu is like a long flowy dress yeah Oh
I thought we were talking about it
I just let that one go yeah
um Park okay okay wait would you watch
this movie with your parents Ashley did
we the first time I watched we watched
the movie with the live audience my
parents were there this is their first
like premiere of any sort I blacked out
for it but
um I also didn't tell them anything
about the movie and so we got to the
point all of them thought I was kidding
but I really didn't and so I was just
like they if they watched the whole
movie it'll be fine but
um I did record their reactions to
watching certain parts of it
which I haven't watched back yet because
I'm too scared but they loved it they
they're really good at dissociating what
do they call it oh the next time my mom
the breakfast she was like oh I met the
actor who was in your wrestling scene
and I was like when was there a
wrestling scene and my dad was like this
is what she's calling the the sexy yeah
the sexy times and I was like ah
wrestling ah yes
that's what they had the sex talk with
you but they liked it yeah they loved it
actually my dad was laughing a lot no
honestly they're very proud very very
proud
anywho oh would you guys watch it with
your parents yeah I wanted are you gonna
watch it with yours I'm thrilled for my
parents to watch it I already worn them
it's very dirty uh actually the word I
said was perverted because I don't know
the do they know it's the only word I
know in Chinese
that's the only word I knew how to
describe that in Chinese
like perverted dirty like I think I my
mom is not allowed she would just be
like this the whole time
it's giving it's giving Aya you know
giving Aya
I feel like on the I've my parents are
the same way but I feel like I owe them
watching it because even to just like
get this part I had to we had to like
read these lines of Mandarin I had to
call my mom and be like okay like
oh can you tell me how to say
in Chinese and she's like cat so you
know I feel like she deserves to enjoy
you know yeah yeah that's the reason I
I'm yeah I am in this movie too yeah and
your parents visited a set too yeah oh
that was a special moment
they were like okay they're all these
Asian people as extras I think we can
sneak in and they fully did they did
they did not make the cuts but they were
just sort of standing there and the
other exercise was like you can't be on
your phone they were like our kid is in
the movie
my mom was almost at the movie but she
got cut it was the only way to get her
on set because of cool bed right yeah
okay anyways okay what was it like
prepping for the K-pop dancing
um who is the best dancer who's the
worst I didn't mean anything by that
Sabrina
I think Sabrina and Ashley are tied no
no Ashley is like a trained Broadway
dancer and then yeah Sabrina freestyle
yeah Sabrina like dislocates bones yeah
you know what I mean I have to go to the
hospital
you get the best choreographer Joe and
make these amazing Vancouver dancers and
we rehearsed every Saturday leading up
to it and there were some moments where
we're like we're this is what is
happening here but it was really I think
once we got sassy kid at least at least
the two in our yeah we were like we are
hair yeah yeah yeah my body was numb I
don't think we understood that we were
doing like a full-on music video within
this movie like I know we were just
hopping around and then they're like and
then you're in this Jeep and you're
going yeah yeah
it was really fun though honestly I love
being challenged and that was
definition of
um are you guys not gonna answer who was
the worst oh
I'm wondering positive here no Sherry I
think you were the worst no that's just
what I wanted I wanted the reassurance
I don't think we we're not a we're not a
core four language of work yeah there's
no hierarchy here yeah Sabrina likes to
live loves the board games
okay whose personality is closest to
your on-screen character Sherry I think
Sherry no but she doesn't fall through
with the
I feel very aligned with Lolo I do when
I first read the script they had asked
me to read for lolo and I literally read
the script and I was like no no no I
know Sherry Cola and this is Sherry Cola
right yeah and a lot of the images I
should be a casting director you are a
casting character no but yeah
we all have like versions of our
character within us though I think the
least like character is probably Dead
Eye yeah that's what I keep trying to
push as a narrative but
it's hard because Dead Eye is hot and
Sabrina is hot so it's just like hard to
you know it's like right Jedi and I were
hot in our own special way people I've
hooked up with have called me an
acquired taste I try not to think about
it I try not to think about it I know
what else is caviar and that's expensive
Tombstone acquired Ten Weeks okay
wait let me ask one yeah yeah what is
your go-to traditional Chinese food dish
oh my God
being
yesterday I was comparing my butt to an
onion pancake and I was like oh
delicious conversation hence the Crave
it was a walk and talk we were giving
walk and talk there was a Steadicam
a drone there was a drone
um Shalom Bao always hits but if we're
talking Niche Niche niche salty duck egg
oh yes thousand-year-old egg which wink
wink to the movie wink wait but you guys
don't actually drink it in the Vodka
right I fully drank it oh no no no no no
no no yeah yeah I would say like
I'm not trying he's fine
um I would say don't cut that
um my favorite Chinese dish is um uh
flaming duck ah with all of the like the
sliced cucumbers and actually my
favorite is a lazy Susan the device
lazy
so lazy we went to dinner last night and
we were at a you know an American
restaurant and the table was hella
rectangular and I was like hello
I was like can you give me some of that
Knights of the Round Table they figured
also conversations uh that yeah you just
you know you wanna we light to moderate
I know that's just right entire
interviews
Ashley's eyes
um great I'm gonna go another one
who is your ideal road trip partner I'm
gonna say celebrity ideal dream road
trip partner
actually these three are my best friends
I love them they're my family our
replies don't need to be funny acquired
taste yeah acquired taste Aubry Plaza or
you
I'm a switch so I sort of would let
offers two verse sorry what I would say
is Stanley Tucci tell us I want a road
trip through Italy with Stanley Tucci
that's a good one
I don't even have an
answering everyone else's answers I
guess well Celine Dion she sings me the
whole world no I actually want to make
her want to sing on her day off you know
what I'm saying right on her travel day
I feel like she is the voice like God
touched her so she's like yeah you do in
battle yeah let's get guessed you know
[Laughter]
Sports voting Braxton Trey Song
[Music]
[Laughter]
partner because he's living the life he
drives to every city eating at every
restaurant that's why I would actually
say well I mean also wait what was the
question
road trip celebrity someone obviously I
would say Florence puke because she's my
friend and we always want to do road
trip together and she's a celebrity
right yeah that's true okay and that
gives back to all of you all four of us
together forever if you could give
advice to one of your co-stars
characters what would it be
if I could give advice to cat cat don't
apologize for who you are he'll love you
still unclench unclenched uh-huh I would
say that to everyone I feel like lolos
would be like lunch
[Laughter]
you know
ignorance is bliss
I know the Silence Is Us truly thinking
about it I was being like is it special
many moments oh how do you measure
[Music]
spoilers left and right I think we have
a picture of this maybe I think we we
got together us for for a little
rehearsal before we started
um right before we started filming in
one of our apartments and we like had
food and we were just like fussing
around yeah and stuff and that was like
I think that it felt special because I
think I knew no matter what happened
with the movie that this was like a this
was a very special moment and we are
gonna make a thing together and that
felt very meaningful so yeah it felt
cohesive from the from the jump very
pedestrian all throughout like family
dinners board games yeah all the stuff
the bonding you know uh you're right
because when we got together to just
rehearse the I'm stronger than I look
um
the K-Pop song for the table read oh
right that's what we were doing it was
so cohesive and so like telepathical
telepathical that's my second language
no it's not yeah it is oh really I'm an
immigrant Cherry Cola pleasure
no Sherry Dr Pepper Sherry Park Sherry
shoes Sherry
I feel like it was when our first group
dinner at Maine oh yeah our first group
dinner
um in Vancouver
the Thai food yeah not Thai food that
was really special we just love eating
that's when I was talking about that
yeah I was talking about that earlier
and that's a big part of the movie as
well Sherry orders as if today were the
last the last every meal is my first and
my last yeah a mukbang I order at a
restaurant as if I have three million
subscribers on YouTube that is how I
order you will okay ready for Rapid Fire
yeah road trip most likely rapid fire
most likely to be the Navigator
Ashley oh interesting I was gonna say me
as well
I mean it depends on if we are we like
our question today yeah okay well yeah I
could do it on the phone but I mean yeah
it's I mean Siri's doing the work I feel
like yeah let's be honest you're an
adventurer though I would trust your
Navigator
um fall asleep at the wheel oh that's me
no it's me yeah
no the public spaces constantly
and and on a couch and like I you know
it's it's this is actually so
comfortable for me like when I'm
surrounded by people and like well lit
nothing scary everyone's happy music on
blast driving yeah but unfortunately I
actually have fallen asleep
that's why if we're talking about the
actual situation what are you talking
about when it was like 2015. are you
okay I'm I'm here now that's all that
matters how'd you wake up
it was a side swipe Collision luckily we
were the only two cars on the freeway at
like 6 a.m it was it was a lot it was a
lot okay
this is
hilarious
take over the aux cord what's aux cord
aux
right auxiliary yeah
DJ oh I would say cheer you could teach
me or Sabrina yeah
um I feel like I mean this is
well okay whatever okay who would wander
off alone
it's Stephanie yeah who would wander off
Stephanie and not bring a phone yeah
Stephanie will be unreachable for three
months but you just have to trust it
wait the best is that
all the question back over here
like months ago
after radio silence
later he was on the way to Austin
oh I don't know I haven't heard about
that we're like that was a question
about a dinner eight months
we have to find the exact things
Stephanie just uh discovered the reply
feature and iMessage it's going back to
says from 2019.
okay
to all day Sherry I have my moments no I
would love to it depends on the hotel
here's the thing despite what it may
look like started off friends
Kelly Clarkson is always relevant yeah
uh I love peace and quiet and Solitude
believe it or not so sometimes I'll just
you know hermit shell hermit shell what
is a hermit crab yeah
okay who's most likely to make new
friends
Cherry I just can't help it
I feel like Sabrina would have the
lifelong friend you know like we talked
about one person at a gas station you'd
be like wow right sometimes I'm in the
morning because quantity quality but eye
contact is a blessing and a curse okay
ready who is most likely to make an
itinerary
Ashley
I love to have an itinerary so that I
could be spontaneous and go off the
itinerary I have to say Ashley is very
organized
no but in this recipe for that thank you
a little bit okay I don't know about
emails but like when I go into your when
I go into your hotel room and things
like that the jewelry is all set I live
out of a luggage Open Face Sandwich okay
last one who is more slightly to ignore
the itinerary
I think maybe Sabrina yeah when I see
those things my my this part of my brain
hurts yeah yeah you just rip it but
Sabrina would appreciate it and be like
that's so great for you yeah yeah and
then I would respond to it eight months
later I'd be like oh no I don't think I
I wanna
um get coffee there yeah yeah yeah